I certainly have learned to first ask
who the director is obviously the script
and the character is important but
filmmaking is a director's medium in my
point of view and you really need to be
able to trust that director work with
that director and know that that
director is going to push to get the
best out of you I love to do a scene 20
different ways but I can only play and
go off in this tangent that tangent if
I'm really conferring the director knows
exactly what he wants from the scene and
knows that he's gonna get that and you
might get some surprises if you go left
and right but if that makes sense the
directors that I most like working with
give you a freedom within these
boundaries it's kind of like parenting
though because we are kids after all
and then when I'm in rehearsal I like to
collaborate I like to talk I like to
rehearse some directors don't like to
rehearse and I respect that
but I'm open I talk about my process to
them I talk about how I'm feeling I talk
about questions I have even ones that
might a feet up here or I'm worried or
stupid questions I'll always get them
out because I think the last thing you
ever want to have in front of the camera
is doubt in any way shape or form about
the character you're playing about what
you story you're trying to tell about
what you're trying to achieve I
genuinely like to be friendly with
everyone in the Australian film industry
everyone talks to everyone and if
they're not making fun of you then they
really don't like you so there's a
problem and I also when I first went to
America I noticed there was an unspoken
it's not people tell stories have don't
look this actor in the eye and all that
I've never heard that before but there
is a slightly unwritten rule of leave
the actor alone let them do their thing
it could be our process it could be
because their style not sure and I
always try literally on the first day to
break that down because I feel
self-conscious in that environment I'd
much prefer a grip you know making fun
of me then calling me mr. Jackman and
then not saying nothing until they say
thank you for there's been great working
with you you know I much
prefer to feel we're in it together when
I first began to get over my nerves or
auditioning I used to always go into an
audition as though it was a rehearsal
more like the first rehearsal so I would
always ask the director or casting agent
whoever was questions if they said look
I think you should sit sit down the
chair say you know I think the character
would stand it was just my lip way of
trying to redress the balance and so I
wasn't just you've got all the power and
I'm trying to please you but rather
we're trying to work together so that
was how I and that seemed to work I
often get that advice to young actors I
certainly think Wolverine was a risk for
me when I first got it thankfully nobody
really knew who I was I mean in the
comic book he was five foot five and not
really the kind of personality that I am
so no one really knew that so I got to
thankfully just go in an audition but
only I had never heard of x-men when I
got the job and I started telling people
and when I was shooting it as well only
when I started to realize the immense
passion that the fans have and how
important that role was and potentially
what was at stake for me I reveled in
the physical side of Wolverine I took it
very seriously I spent a long time
studying animals and trying to work out
ways to incorporate what had been an
image on a page for 40 years and how to
make that work the art in the comic
books itself was really informative I
used to kind of some of those moves in
there and those artists their economy
that how they can tell so much of an
entire fight and maybe eight frames it
was extraordinary so I really drew on
them and the movement to me has always
been very important I will spend
sometimes hours walking around a room
inhabiting a character and I might just
start from the top down or from the feet
from the toes right through to the top
my head imagining how their character
walks how that character sits how their
character holds himself when they're
angry how they sleep all that stuff
because
it really informs how you play the
character I remember a McKellen saying
to me just because it feels
uncomfortable doesn't mean it's not good
and I remember I am I doing the first
x-men movie was a little I came in late
I felt a bit behind the 8-ball I started
shooting four weeks into filming because
I was replacing the guy who was playing
the role so I came in feeling a bit
behind the eight ball and there was a
rhythm going and I I just felt a bit
uncomfortable and and I I remember him
giving me that advice he goes your stuff
is good and on even if it feels
uncomfortable that can sometimes be
right I think so often not only on film
but in life we so want to feel
comfortable but that doesn't always
bring the best results if I look back I
think some of my more successful things
and my point of view have been the
things I've been most nervous about and
probably most unsure when I began
there's something about jumping off that
cliff which means you end up going for
broke and probably end up taking a few
more risks if you know what I mean and I
would say that young actors it's okay to
be nervous
say you nervous I used to by the way for
20 years I never did I hit it
tried to hide it say it and it's usually
relieving to everyone around you maybe
not on the 20th take but certainly when
you walk in it's fine
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]